[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia se cumplen 200 años de la
muerte de napoleón bonaparte
el soldado general y también emperador
francés quien a principios del siglo 19
puso en jaque a europa occidental
el genio militar y líder visionario
murió en el exilio el 5 de mayo de 1821
habían discurrido seis años de su
destierro en la remota isla británica de
santa elena en el atlántico sur un
destino azotado por el viento e
infestado de ratas durante esos años
napoleón estuvo rodeado de un grupo de
confidentes como también de una
guarnición de tres mil soldados
británicos que lo acechaban para
frustrar sus intenciones de escape la
figura de napoleón aún hoy sigue
dividiendo las opiniones para algunos es
un célebre comandante que levantó un
vasto imperio y construyó en francia un
moderno estado centralizado para otros
fue un tirano despótico que sucumbió
ante su eterno rival los ingleses
batalla de waterloo de 1815 en santa
elena
napoleón habitó la long house su último
hogar y el de su séquito de 28 personas
se dice que el séquito que siguió
voluntariamente a napoleón en su exilio
consumía 17 botellas de vino al día por
no contar las de champán y otros licores
un hábito consagrado para aliviar la
impotencia del destierro tanto como la
intensa humedad del clima entre bebidas
en la casa long but napoleón pasaba los
días leyendo la historia de su vida a
sus compatriotas con profunda atención
sus seguidores le escuchaban las
anécdotas desde sus orígenes genoveses
en la isla de córcega hasta sus hazañas
militares que le llevaron a extender el
radio de su imperio en europa occidental
a finales del siglo 18 napoleón caló
entre los franceses en un momento de
inflexión histórica la revolución
francesa habiendo tomado la senda
militar ascendió vertiginosamente en la
jerarquía
castrense al nunca defraudar a sus
superiores un ejemplo ocurrió en 1795
cuando los franceses se levantaron en
una insurrección pro monárquica que
pedía el fin de la república y la
restauración del rey en su trono pero
napoleón a cargo de un ejército
improvisado defendió el palacio de las
tullerías sofocó con artillería la
insurrección contra revolucionaria y se
ganó el respeto y la admiración de los
jacobinos de acuerdo con la historiadora
francesa léa charly card napoleón quería
ser recordado como un emperador caído
que murió a miles de kilómetros de
francia sobre una pequeña roca volcánica
un emperador que nunca abandonó su
investidura de soldado como lo demuestra
su uniforme azul su sombrero bicorne y
su lecho de muerte un catre militar de
hierro liso como parte de sus memorias
escritas en la remota isla
napoleón consignó sus primeros años a
cargo de misiones cruciales para francia
en la geopolítica de finales de 1700
entre ellas se cuenta ganar con un
ejército harapiento y mal alimentado
batallas al norte de italia
la ocupación de venecia luego de mil
años de independencia el sometimiento de
austria a sus órdenes y la confiscación
de países bajos y el territorio del ring
y es que los éxitos militares de
napoleón le acarrearon fama a lo largo y
ancho de europa se hablaba de su
profundo conocimiento a la hora de
aplicar tácticas militares así como de
su ingenio y su creatividad para
desarticular los ejércitos de los
enemigos más poderosos dicho prestigio
le valió para comandar al ejército
francés en una expedición por egipto por
entonces una provincia del imperio
otomano con el objetivo de cortar las
rutas británicas hacia la india
en efecto napoleón venció con 25 mil
hombres a 100.000 soldados británicos en
la batalla de las pirámides pero
registró un duro golpe en su contra
el célebre almirante nelson destruyó
toda la flota francesa en la batalla del
nilo ensalzado por sus victorias
napoleón regresó a francia donde
autoproclamó en 1799 como primer cónsul
en 1802 como primer cónsul vitalicio y
en 1804 como emperador de los franceses
en su calidad de emperador napoleón
recapituló una serie de batallas sobre
las monarquías europeas las cuales se
aliaron para hacerle contrapeso al
expansionismo francés en 1805 la marina
inglesa se mostró invencible en la
batalla de trafalgar
pero napoleón fue avasallante en la
batalla de austerlitz de 1806 habiendo
conquistado gran parte de europa
occidental los enemigos más fuertes de
napoleón seguían siendo los ingleses y
los rusos justamente la fallida invasión
contra estos últimos fue el comienzo de
su declive de los 600.000 hombres que
envió en 1812 para combatir en el gélido
territorio ruso menos de 100 mil
regresaron en pie
disminuido napoleón fracasó una vez más
en la batalla de waterloo en 1815 cuando
cayó prisionero de los británicos
todas estas batallas fueron consignadas
por napoleón en sus memorias durante su
exilio en la isla de santa elena antes
de morir de cáncer de estómago una de
las tantas teorías que rondan alrededor
de su fallecimiento dos décadas después
de haber sido enterrado por los ingleses
en la isla de santa elena los franceses
lograron repatriar sus restos para
conservarlos hasta el día de hoy en el
complejo de los inválidos de parís un
hombre que marcó con guerras y leyes el
inicio de la historia contemporánea de
europa así concluimos hoy andrés suárez
jaramillo gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]